you have been a director well I've also
here just you say realizer for over 50
years how long did it take you to master
the craft of directing of filmmaking you
never stop learning how to make a
builtin I've directed since nineteen
fifty-five I'm still learning all art is
like that you never and if you ever get
self-satisfied that's the you're
finished y'all always gotta you know the
great liner has rebound about art make
it you that's my motto I used to have it
over my kind of your communicator groups
make it you don't do the thing you've
done in the past make something
different equally valuable equally valid
but make it new so I think that's that's
always been inside the model of my work
you